drake is celebrating his little boy's
big day i'm excited about it the
certified lover boy artist rang in his
son adonis's fourth birthday on sunday
posting some super sweet snaps on
instagram that's the 34 year old with
his son grinning ear to ear rocking a
long-sleeved black shirt and camo pants
bending down to get close to the
birthday boy as they stood in front of a
race car themed backdrop the decor
included black and white checkered
balloons and a poster that read adonis
races into four you know i hope i made
him proud drake captioned the sweet
father-son post quote teach a more life
kid the rapper also shared this clip to
his insta story adonis eating some
popcorn and having a quick chat with
bugs bunny
[Music]
later the grammy winner shared this
black and white snapshot from the photo
booth that's the proud dad beaming as he
lifts his son in the air and can we talk
about how cute adonis is giving us major
superman vibes
adonis's mom sophie brousseau also
commemorated the day on instagram
posting these sweet throwback snaps
along with pics of her son at his b day
bash there's adonis posing it up with
bugs bunny and that's the four-year-old
in the photo booth she captioned the
post quote my life truly started four
years ago mon petite adonis
[Music]
drake confirmed he had a son in june
2018 on his album scorpion a month after
pusha t released the story of adidon a
diss track that suggested drake may have
fathered a child a baby's involved it's
deeper than rap we talking character let
me keep with the facts you are hiding a
child let that boy come home deadbeat
[ __ ] playing border patrol
adonis is your son drake first shared
photos of his son on social media in
march 2020 posting several shots with
adonis
in may 2021 drake brought his little guy
with him to the billboard music awards
and even let him hold his trophy as he
accepted the award for artist of the
decade
[Music]